i did see chris that there was a japan
times article that heavily featured you
which is discussing
the reaction videos about japan yeah was
there a japan times article yeah that
was the japanese
first time i really heard about it for
some reason since september there's been
about 25
reaction videos for in japan from
primarily japanese
uh youtubers and i i didn't know that i
thought there was like two or three then
i read the article
what japan titus which they felt that
was a topic right right i'm great they
did thank you japan times but
they they were like it's becoming really
popular i think people are getting
really interested in
hearing what japanese people think of
foreigners living in japan and kind of
reacting to it
but then when you ask them they're just
like i don't [ __ ] care yeah they're
i think people want it to be a lot more
interesting than it actually is yeah and
i've watched a few and
that's the thing i'd be more inclined to
hear what a japanese person would think
if they were actually giving
you know an opinion yeah they're not
they're usually just like i mean there's
someone who doesn't really
understand why reaction videos are good
i found it quite difficult to grasp
and i've watched a few and you know
because of japanese they're very nice
and kind and polite
british they'd be like this guy's a
brick yeah what's he talking about
but i would argue that's more of an
interesting content right like at least
you get to hear someone's opinion
whether it be
positive or negative rather than just
you know like on the fence type of like
oh yes yes this is a video indeed it's
just if someone watches your video and
they're silent and they get a million
views there's something about that
that's like
okay but like one guy did do that yeah
yeah he's just he's just going
it's just me saying something like don't
do this it's literally just a million
people
he's going for an anime reaction so like
how
many videos does your original video i
mean how many
how much sake have you had let me let me
rephrase that how many views does your
original video have
i i don't actually know i think it's
like 10 million views
they have been reacting to most i think
right yeah because i find that
like i i have like a few like videos
that people react to as well
and for some reason like all of them
just blow up
like compared to like any of my other
videos they all like do amazingly well
so i feel like you know it's it's weird
seeing someone react to your videos
uh especially especially if it's just
like okay
and it's i i don't know how so i i
assume you've watched people react to
your videos
it's like two or three and they're all
right they're nice they're great
respectful
one the one that i did of the one i
think the most successful one that's got
millions of views
it's weird someone's got millions of
like views uh
millions of views reacting to my video
it's that's kind of surreal but
how do you feel about them possibly
making you know a few thousand dollars
off of that
i don't really mind to be honest i'm not
that bothered
i'm curious because every creator tends
to have a different kind of how would
you feel about it
and you've probably had that i've i've
had that ah i can't remember if i have i
don't think i have but i think it would
probably
i'm just clearly not interesting enough
chris you're truly
broccoli i mean it's i guess again i
wouldn't do anything
but i might just like mutter i might be
like oh
i think if they're funny i'll be like
cracking that's fantastic but if they're
just kind of like like you said just
kind of um
agitated one of them the main one the
guy's got the most views nice bloke
he uh disagreed with my number one point
on my what to do in japan number one
point is
don't walk down the street in japan and
eat and drink while you're walking
it's not like a law right you're gonna
get arrested for doing that yeah but
people will be like just like social
earnings people look at you and be like
what the [ __ ] are they doing yeah like
yeah because in japan there's not that
many
like you never see anyone like or trash
cans
in the street right and so you don't you
know you can't throw your stuff away but
like
like there's a reason why the streets of
japan are so clean they're very clean
and yeah people don't tend to
eat and walk but this guy's like oh no
we do do that in japan and osaka you can
do it and it's like
osaka is different and in downtown osaka
you can do it because lots of stands for
like takoyaki yeah fried oculus balls
and there's kind of that
street food culture it is but that's
only really an osaka
there's not many other places yeah you
can do that maybe asakusa
in tokyo but in north japan if you do
that people will be like yeah i i do
foreign
i will admit i do do it when i'm in a
bit of a rush but it's like in the room
sometimes yeah chris i'm breaking the
law what am i going to do disrespecting
the culture
as always listen sometimes i got to be
somewhere and i i need [ __ ] food and
i haven't got time to
sit here and give a [ __ ] about like
standing in the family mart depressed
and eating it i'ma [ __ ] walk and
shove it down my throat why are you
laughing chris
it is how it is what you just described
is something i do like every week
you see them there in the in the family
mart looking out the window like caged
animals like
just wishing wishing they could walk
free
and eat their chicken but sadly they
can't
but like yeah i think that was the only
point you disagreed with and it made the
video feel a bit redundant
yeah i feel like if there's somebody's
like oh he's a foreigner in japan
he doesn't know what he's talking about
maybe he's not good because he's not
japanese you know
if you just say that's not what they
think
i'm thinking of doing like a react video
to the react videos in the reaction
please don't react
that would be amazing those are always
the funniest i've got a headache just
saying it out loud
but it would be like inception of
reaction and i've got like 25 videos
that i can go through you have to do it
now because you've said it yeah yeah
that will get a million views yeah that
would have been a lot yeah i don't get a
lot of views what would i kill the video
chris reacts to being reacted to chris
people reacting to chris
that's that's the most confusing thing
that's amazing because you see that in
your sub box you're like well i have to
watch this this is a [ __ ] mess
i think felix did i think felix did that
a while back where he did uh
pewdiepie reacts to uh it was like
one of the fine bros episodes of them
reacting to pewdiepie
yeah and then sometimes feinberg has
even gone far enough to show that
and do like four four levels of
reactions yeah
it's like a reply chain for me it's just
like the lowest form of content isn't it
in some respects
go for it
what's the bottom of the barrel god
describe to me the bottom of the barrel
contact down the barrel
why not create against reaction videos i
watch a lot of reactions like video
games and things but
yeah i don't know when i looked
[Laughter]
but i feel like it's very much like as
someone who spends
way too much time trying to make their
bloody videos
to is someone just watch my video be
like oh [ __ ] it's good
yeah you know minnie mouse i think a
million views just like oh [ __ ] sake
why would i bother like
why don't you do that maybe i should be
a youtuber
and then you try it and you just like
drink sucky i'll be really bitter and
angry and i'll swear those would be
brilliant
i mean that'd be hilarious to watch
personally let's do it live let's do it
now let's do it don't do it
trust me chase reacts yeah let's see
why you're dancing away
did you like my paul dancing chris it's
you three such an interesting
trio of characters you've got gandhi
does these it's slickly produced
and then you've got joey's at the
forefront of otaku culture and animation
[Music]
i love i love how you slipped into your
abroad in japan voice there yeah
right yeah all right yeah there's a
difference look at these
three youtubers one glass of stuff my i
guess my channel is the throw [ __ ] at
the wall and just make
and make it all stick if not just glue
it back on if it falls off
three very diverse kind of characters
three diverse topics
i mean i feel like this year trash taste
has pretty much been the only
big thing that's happened to me last
year gone [ __ ] yeah
20 21. we're not filming this in 2020
sorry this is being
been produced live apparently
only hours after recording it this man
has four sips of sake forgets the
english language oh the salad okay
yeah i had a [ __ ] power sausage vodka
in it
i will i will drink it all chris weevil
drunk will suck yeah
you can't what is a new year's episode
without the host getting like
belligerently drunk
you know what what a great introduction
to 2021 it's just four pieces
i'm not seeing enough connor into
drinking stuff let's turn it from a
discussion to a [ __ ] just
bar conversation i was just [ __ ]
shouting at each other i'm not gonna lie
half the time i've forgotten okay
like do we even have a topic at this
point we're just chatting [ __ ] we're
just literally chatting [ __ ]
it's the shittiest episode sorry chris
do you have a topic no fantastic
all right why don't you like anime chris
what's up with that
i've got nothing i like anime is great
why do you hate people who like anime
the thing with anime is i watch it and i
go that's good
no the same way a dad sees his son's
hobby that's like
that's fine do it go away but i don't
know where to go from there
i don't know what's the next level so
you're saying if we give you a detailed
guide on how to watch anime you will
then go ahead isn't that what we were
supposed to do in the first night
i mean there's a bunch of [ __ ] what
do you get from anime that you don't get
from live action
kind of films sakuya have you ever heard
of that word
no why were you saying that [ __ ] what
[Music]
because that's like trying to explain
what a bee jupiter is your parents you
know oh yeah
that's true that's true because right
you know japan has a few tv options
right for example
they have you know this amazing anime
with incredible animation voice acting
really crazy plots or
or of course you can watch 24
the japan remake did you know that's a
thing
oh i heard about it it's brand new
they're r it's airing
now and it's no no no no actual live
action
they're completely remaking but i think
in their own plot 24
but just japan you know what it's called
it's called 24
japan that doesn't really work it
doesn't matter it's self-aware and it's
pretty bad
you've watched it yeah i watched an
episode and it was as [ __ ] as you
thought it like really low budget
oh it's like it's japanese jack bauer
yeah yeah
yeah the entire cast the entire cast is
japanese i just think a jack bauer
personality s doesn't really work
no no not in japanese i find japanese
tvs very low budget like trash taste
probably has a bigger budget
tv show i don't know about that we
haven't got a guy reacting can we have
chris's face whenever
on their camera that's why you hate
react channels because that's most of
like japanese tv
you need a react cam in the corner right
absolutely